Photogrammetry is quite straightforward using a smartphone.
There are several apps that make the process painless.
They mostly work the same way with slight variations and limitations.
The idea is to take pictures from different angles around the subject,
and then you process the model onto the cloud before downloading it ready to use.
Some applications won't let you use a turntable,
Epic Games' Reality Scan being one of them.
Many free apps won't let you export a model until you pay for the full version.
The good news is that Reality Scan is free,
but you will need to export your model to Sketchfab first prior to downloading it to a PC.
Other apps, like the free version of Curie Engine, restricts you to only 70 input pictures.
The workflow is usually painless.
Here's a quick example of how Curie Engine operates.
I'm using Curie Engine as an example,
because I'm using a turntable as part of my setup,
and Reality Scan won't let me use that.
With Reality Scan, the model is static and you need to move around it.
At any rate, the process is quite similar between apps.
You start the app, create a new project, take pictures,
try not to change your zoom levels,
but you are encouraged to move in and out to get extra detail.
You then proceed to fill the project data before you send it to the cloud.
Then you wait.
Processing may take a while based on network traffic.
Alternately, the model is created,
and you can preview it before exporting it to your email account.
Although I'm using a turntable in this example,
I will show you one advantage that Reality Scan has over Curie Engine.
When you start a project using Reality Scan,
you can choose to use or disable Auto Capture mode.
I will disable it in this example to have better control of taking pictures,
but you can opt to leave it on.
As you start taking pictures in Reality Scan,
remember again that you must turn around the subject.
Therefore, you need to move the camera around for the app to perform well.
What is different here is that as you take pictures,
the app creates a ghost snapshot of the previous photos.
That makes it easy to see how the photo shoot is proceeding.
Thus, identifying gaps where you need more pictures taken.
I will cancel this project as I cannot go fully around the model using this setup,
but you get the gist.
At any rate, scanning 3D models using a photogrammetry app
means you often need to clean it up before you get it into Unreal Engine.
And so, once you have downloaded it to your PC,
you may want to process it in a DCC application to remove any unwanted data.
In this case, note that not only Leo was scanned,
but also the turntable and a bit of the desktop as well.
So you can use your DCC tools to clean that up
and leave only the part that interests you.
Once you have removed the excess, you can analyze your model.
You'll notice that it generally looks quite good
for the minimal effort you put creating it.
There are some areas that look weaker,
such as the underbelly that didn't have much data to work with.
There weren't many photos taken from that angle.
So, although it's not perfect,
it's still remarkably good for the ease in which it was generated.
From there on, you can export the FBX file over writing the old one
or simply creating a new one
and import it into Unreal Engine as a final model.
Of course, you can always fine-tune things
such as adjusting specular and roughness properties for better results.
In the next video, we look at RealityCapture,
which gives you a wealth of features to output models with a much higher quality.